-Performing "29"
from their new album, "Holy F,"
give it up for Demi Lovato!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Petal on the vine ♪
♪ Too young to drink wine ♪
♪ Just five years a bleeder ♪
♪ Student and a teacher ♪
♪ Far from innocent ♪
♪ What the...consent? ♪
♪ Numbers told you not to ♪
♪ But that didn't stop you ♪
♪♪
♪ Finally 29 ♪
♪ Funny, just like you were
at the time ♪
♪ Thought it was
a teenage dream ♪
♪ A fantasy ♪
♪ But was it yours
or was it mine ♪
♪ 17, 29 ♪
♪ Oh-oh-oh-oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Had me in your grip ♪
♪ Went beautifully with ♪
♪ All my daddy issues ♪
♪ And this...continues ♪
♪ I see you're quite
the collector ♪
♪ Yeah, you're 12 years
her elder ♪
♪ Maybe now it doesn't matter ♪
♪ But I know...better ♪
♪ Yeah, I know...better ♪
♪ Finally 29 ♪
♪ Funny, just like you were
at the time ♪
♪ Thought it was
a teenage dream ♪
♪ A fantasy ♪
♪ But was it yours
or was it mine ♪
♪ 17, 29 ♪
♪ Oh-oh-oh-oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ 17, 29 ♪
♪ Oh-oh-oh-oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Finally 29 ♪
♪ 17 would never cross my mind ♪
♪ Thought it was
a teenage dream ♪
♪ A fantasy ♪
♪ But it was yours,
it wasn't mine ♪
♪ 17, 29 ♪
♪ Oh-oh-oh-oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]